Oh God!
No, no. My god, no.
This is hostility.
I only wrote
the one chapter.
Well, that's
a hell of a chapter.
Did you use really big font?
Hello?
Mr Duchovny?
David?
Hello?
What the actual fuck?
Hey.
Hi. Hi!
I didn't know
anybody was here.
Ji-Yoon?
Yeah.
The… the door was open.
You always leave
your door open?
Never had a problem before.
That's why I love it here.
Nobody bothers you.
Oh God!
You okay?
Yeah. Sorry, for a second,
I thought you were naked.
Interesting.
For the distinguished
lectureship,
I was thinking of presenting
my Yale dissertation.
"The Schizophrenic Critique
of Pure Reason
in Beckett's Early Novels".
I only wrote
the one chapter.
Well, that's
a hell of a chapter.
Did you use really big font?
Nope.
Yeah, I got sidetracked
for a few decades,
but I've been thinking
about finishing it,
you know,
and filing for my PhD.
Dr David Duchovny.
Maybe too much alliteration.
Do you think it's unfair
for people to start thinking
of me as Dr David Duchovny
after thinking of me as
just David Duchovny
for so many years?
Anyway, take a gander.
I reread it last night.
It's… it's pretty good.
Press-ient even.
Press-ient, really?
I think it's pronounced
prescient,
unless we're English.
Aren't we speaking English?
Okay, maybe you chose
the wrong department.
Maybe you're better suited
for the sch-iences.
I don't say that
because you're Asian.
I mean, I don't even know
that you are Asian.
And I don't see colour…
or ethnicity or even faces…
at this point, I just see…
vibe and aura,
and yours is lovely.
I'm going to make
a sch-moothie.
-Like a sch-moothie?
-No, thank you.
Have you been to
the farmers' market here?
No.
Ah, I used to think this
town was devoid of culture,
but I stand corrected.
I mean, look at that carrot.
Anyway,
pretend I'm not here.
I can't just catch you up
with a quick tutorial.
Why not?
Because that's
an insane request.
This is over 30 years old.
A lot has happened
in the last 30 years.
Like what?
Like affect theory,
ecocriticism,
digital humanities,
new materialism,
book history,
gender studies
and critical race theory.
When did you last pick up
an academic journal?
Well, I've been on tour
with my band.
-So…
-It shows.
And you know what else?
The fact that you're using
this honour from Pembroke
to dust off
your dissertation
and go back
and get your PhD,
it's… it's…
it's self-serving.
Whoa, is this hostility
because Pembroke is like
this lower-tier Ivy
and I went to Princeton?
-No!
-And Yale?
No, no. My God, no.
This is hostility
because I promised
this lectureship
to someone who deserves it.
The purpose of the talk
is to present
cutting-edge scholarship.
This reads like
it's out of the mid-80s.
I mean, like the…
The discipline
has moved forward and…
you're still stuck
back in a different era.
I just need a minute.
-Here, can I make a--
-No!
Your maps and geography
When I come back
If I come back
I swear that I'll be simpler
When I come back
If I come back
I'll have a mind of winter
Only song I've ever heard
quote Wallace Stevens.
Fuck, I hope so.
You have a good voice.
Was there someone else
before me?
A celebrity author?
Did Pembroke offer
this position
to someone else first?
It's all right,
I can take it.
There was talk of
James Franco a while back.
Well, he got his PhD
from Yale.
-Did he? He got it?
-Yeah. He did.
He did.
They might have invited
Ethan Hawke,
but he was shooting
in Bulgaria.
What was he shooting?
-Pardon me?
-In Bulgaria?
Well, a movie
or a TV series?
Well, I don't know
what he was shooting.
There's a lot of shooting
in Bulgaria.
Okay.
Look, so…
I did all that work at Yale
on Beckett.
Right? But I figured
I'll just stick with that
and then…
Let's take a swim.
Oh, I don't have
a bathing suit.
Well, you can borrow one.
Here, borrow this one.
Who's… Who wore that?
That's mine.
It's a speed suit.
I wear it when
I wanna swim for time.
Because skin's a drag,
because of hair.
You can't teach Beckett for
the rest of the semester.
Why not? You got Murphy,
Malloy, Malone Dies.
The students bought
the other books.
So I'll reimburse them.
I'm a grossly overpaid
actor-slash-musician
slash-novelist
and they're students,
burdened with student debt.
-I will unburden them.
-I mean…
The syllabus is a contract
You can't just change--
Let's go for a swim.
You know what?
Teaching is not a pastime,
it's a profession.
If you really want to make
a contribution to the field,
tell them you've changed
your mind
give them a cheque to endow
a chair in your name,
and I'll get you
an honorary doctorate.
The David Duchovny Chair
in English Studies?
The Dr David Duchovny Chair
in English Studies.